if you're a sucker for forbidden love
stories you're going to love five feet
apart this tragic love story is sure to
hit you right in the fields so bring
some tissues with you to the theater
watch until the end to find out which
five feet apart fact has got fans shook
by feet apart are you in the Disney
connection this star's if I feet apart
have something huge in common
hey Lee Lou Richardson Cole Sprouse and
Moses areas have all starred on the
Disney Channel there's no doubt that the
Disney Channel is amazing at finding
talented actors so where have you seen
all of these stars before Cole Sprouse
is obviously one of the two stars of The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody
Cole played Cody while his twin brother
Dylan played Zac : Dylan also got a
spinoff series called the suite life on
deck Healey Lu didn't have her own show
but she did guest star on shake it up in
2013 she played the role of a dancer
Moises arias plays Poe in five feet
apart
he has guest-starred on Disney Channel
several times he was on three episodes
of Wizards of Waverly Place he voiced a
character on Phineas and Ferb and was
also in Hannah Montana the movie but the
Disney connection goes even deeper Moses
made a guest appearance on sweet life
way back in 2006 that means that he
shared a screen with Cole before this
movie guess who else made an appearance
in sweet life the director
Justin Baldoni it's pretty cool that all
these former Disney actors have grown up
to do more serious films from
documentary shorts to chick flicks 5
feet apart is totally amazing it's
likely to go down as one of the best
tragic romances in history and we just
know that Justin Baldoni did an epic job
directing he probably has tons of
directing experience right well not
exactly
this is Justin's first time directing a
feature-length fiction movie
Justin's directing experience is pretty
much limited to documentaries most of
the documentaries are short films he did
direct one miniseries with 8 episodes
this series was a continuation of some
other short Docs he made there called my
last days they're all about people who
live with terminal illness he interviews
people with different illnesses that
know that they won't live
he does a great job of revealing the
person behind the illness he shows how
courageous these people are and how they
live their short lives to the fullest so
we can see why he's so passionate about
five feet apart he'll be able to reach a
whole new audience by advocating a
similar message we're excited to see him
enter a whole new territory with this
love story Justin has another
documentary coming out soon called
laughing at my nightmare
the best critic we just loved Cole
Sprouse the Riverdale star has stolen
our hearts ever since he was a kid on
Disney Channel we aren't the only ones
who love him Cole is dating Lilly
Reinhardt
she plays Betty Cooper on Riverdale the
love interest of his character Jughead
they're seriously relationship Bulls and
Lilly is Cole's biggest fan and best
critic she posted photos on an Instagram
from the premiere of bye feet apart and
she had the nicest things to say she
said she is in awe of : hailey loo for
their work in the film she said the last
few days have been challenging for all
of them she was referring to the sudden
loss of Luke Perry and then she goes on
to say how this new movie is so touching
she said that it made her grateful to be
with the people she loves
she was super moved by the film and
can't wait for the rest of the world to
see it Wow
if that's not the best review ever we
don't know what is we think it's so
great that Lilly is supportive of her
boyfriend's project we just know how
proud she is of him we hope that the
release of this movie brought some joy
to the Riverdale actors after the loss
of their beloved co-star there's a novel
after the success of The Fault in Our
Stars many people have wondered if this
new movie is based on a book it's just
life it'll be over before you know it
these young adult romance novels are all
the rage just look at Netflix is success
turning books into teen chick flicks
well 5 feet apart is not based on a book
but there is a novel version Rachael
Lippincott is a brand-new author she was
chosen by the publisher Simon & Schuster
to turn the screenplay into a novel the
screenplay was written by Niki Daughtry
and Tobias Ike honest it was written
first and production on the movie had
already started but since the why a
genre is doing so well the publisher
knew it had the potential to become a
best-selling novel and just check out
the gorgeous cover those
flowers look like lungs to represent
cystic fibrosis what an awesome book
cover the book dropped in November of
2018 so if you'd rather read the book
before seeing the movie head to your
local library or bookstore Simon &
Schuster does a great job at picking
authors we just know that this book will
be as epic as the movie have you read
the book if so let us know what
differences there are between the novel
and the film in the comment section
below
the big what-ifs some people have
pointed out that five feet apart sounds
a lot like The Fault in Our Stars but
there are some really major differences
cystic fibrosis patients have to be
really isolated because they're in
danger of getting an infection and a
regular infection that may make someone
miss school for a day could kill a
cystic fibrosis patient it's an awful
way to live and two people with cystic
fibrosis have to stay at least 6 feet
apart at all times in the trailer the
characters are being constantly reminded
of this 6 feet at all times you both
know the rules but when will convinces
Stella that life is worth a little risk
they start standing five feet apart the
movie wanted to ask some big questions
what if the person you love the most in
the world was someone you couldn't touch
what if the most intimate relationship
you have can't involve any physical
intimacy and can love transcend the need
for a human touch we're crying just
thinking about it these are some pretty
huge questions to answer in a movie but
obviously Justin in the cast are up for
the challenge one thing is for sure this
will be a totally different movie than
we've ever seen the soundtrack is lit
you might have noticed some awesome
music in the trailer it left us
wondering about the soundtrack the
soundtrack was released on the same day
as the movie and it is totally lit
there's remind me to forget that kygo
which features Miguel just the name of
the song makes us want to cry Andy
Grammer also has a song on the
soundtrack it's called don't give up on
me you can stream those two songs
separately most of the soundtrack is
downright amazing it was composed by
Brian Tyler and Breton Vivian Brian
wrote the score for Avengers age of
Ultron and crazy rich Asians Breton
worked on crazy rich Asians with Brian
he also wrote the score for the Netflix
series galavant you
know that these two working together are
going to make some awesome music there's
also a bonus track by Kate Davis it's
called my baby just cares for me it's so
sweet and so romantic dance I've been
wondering where the idea for five feet
apart came from stay tuned to find out
from actor to director we've already
talked about Justin Baldoni s experience
as a director but you're probably
thinking that this guy looks really
familiar
that's because he's also a famous actor
Justin stars on the CW's hit show Jane
the virgin he plays Raphael who is
Jane's boss and also the father of her
baby
there is plenty of money he later
becomes Jane's love interest Justin's
acting experience goes way back he got
his start on the soap opera The Young
and the Restless back in 2004 he also
had a role in the short-lived series
Everwood in 2010 he went back to the
soap opera world eat a recurring role on
the bold and the beautiful he's had
several small roles on lots of
television shows he also starred in a
short film that he directed called 73
questions with Logan Rawlings he even
shared the screen with Ashley Tisdale
yep he worked with a former co-star of
Cole Sprouse Justin's been in a few
indie movies too but he got on
everyone's radar with the success of
Jane the Virgin he can act and direct
we're so excited to see him transition
into the role of director for this film
it makes grown men cry if you're like us
you probably teared up just watching the
trailer and if you're really like us you
probably kept crying throughout the
whole movie
we know this movie is going to be sad
the two main characters have a terminal
illness but how sad is this movie
well according to Cole Sprouse it's a
real tearjerker he posted a photo of the
stars with their director from the
premiere on Instagram in his post he
revealed that his brother Dylan and
their dad both cried Cole said seeing
these two men cry in a room full of
women in business professionals is
something he'll smile about for the rest
of his life it sounds like he teased his
family for crying but did Cole cry at
the premiere well according to his
Instagram he didn't he says anyone that
saw him crying is being deceived
huh jerk ol just admit it it's okay to
cry
especially when viewing such a sweet and
tragic love story
move over Romeo and Juliet it's time for
Stella grant and will Newman to be the
new icons of tragic love stories we'll
never know for sure if Coll cried but if
fans have learned anything from his
revelation it's to bring a box of
tissues with them to the movie theater
not everyone's a fan people everywhere
are looking forward to the release of
this movie it's going to be a girls
night classic for years to come but not
everyone is thrilled about the film in
fact the biggest critics come from
people who really live with cystic
fibrosis and they have some valid
concerns first of all being six feet
apart from another patient is the bare
minimum that's only if they absolutely
have to be in the same room in real life
they shouldn't spend time in the same
room at all it's just too dangerous
director Justin Baldoni admits that they
had to take some creative liberties to
make this story but he did work closely
with real-life patients to make it as
accurate as possible also a lot of
people who live with cystic fibrosis are
upset at the whole premise of the movie
they don't want their disease
romanticized we can understand that it's
a really serious disease they don't want
people to think it's some sweet romantic
life on the flip side other patients say
that any exposure is good exposure many
people have probably never heard of
cystic fibrosis before this film more
awareness of a disease means more money
for research and that's always a good
thing
true story despite what the critics may
say the cast and crew of five feet apart
did their homework they worked closely
with an organization called Clare's
place foundation it's a great
organization they provide all sorts of
assistance to families living with
cystic fibrosis it can be financial help
or emotional support
Claire's place was founded by Claire
Weinland and she is the inspiration
behind Stella in the movie Claire was
awesome she was a YouTube star who made
videos with real talk about living with
cystic fibrosis many of you probably
wondering what is with the oxygen she
spent a huge chunk of her life in
hospitals
she played games with the nurses and was
a fan of glitter bombs
or not that she once snuck out of the
hospital to attend a political rally
when she was just 13 years old she was
in a coma for over two weeks after that
she set up her foundation sadly Claire
passed away in September of 2018 just
one week after a lung transplant she was
just 21 there inspired and helped a lot
of people in her life and she even
helped out with five feet apart her
legacy will live on forever so are you
excited to see five feet apart let us
know in the comments thank you for
watching and make sure to subscribe to
the things for more videos like this one
we'll see you next time
[Music]